let's now consider two dimensional
motion and let's try to analyze how to
describe the change in velocity so again
let's choose a coordinate system we have
an Origin plus y plus X and let's draw
the trajectory of our object and now
let's draw the object at two different
times so for instance if I call this the
location at time t1 and a little bit
later here this is the location of the
object at time T to call our unit
vectors I hat in Jacob now we know that
the direction the velocity is tangent to
this curve so if we draw the at time t1
and over here notice the direction has
changed the at time t2 and what we'd
like to do now is describe just as
before that our acceleration a of T is
the derivative of the velocity as a
function of time what that means is the
limit as delta T goes to 0 of Delta V
over delta T now it's much harder to
visualize the Delta V in this drawing
and partly the reason for that is these
velocity vectors are located at two
different points and right now they're
the backs of these vectors of different
places in space but remember that Delta
V is just the in this case at time t2
minus V at time t1 and our principle for
subtracting two vectors at different
locations in space is to draw the
vectors where we put the tails at the
same location so here's a tail of this
vector we're just going to translate
that vector in space that is still the
at time t1 these vectors are equal they
have the same length and they have the
same direction
and so Delta V is just the vector that
connects here to there that's what we
mean by Delta V and so you can see in
this particular case that it's not
obvious from looking at the orbit what
the Delta V is so what we need to do is
just trust our calculus and so when we
write the velocity as DX DT I have plus
dy/dt J hat and we're now treating each
direction independently we call this V X
uh-huh plus V Y J hat so that's our
velocity vector then our acceleration is
just the derivative of the velocity we
take each direction separately so we
have DV X DT I hat plus DV y dt j huh
now again notice that velocity V of X is
already the first derivative of the
position of the X component function so
what we really have here is a is the
second derivative of the position
function in the I hat direction and the
second derivative of the component
function in the Y direction and that is
what we call the instantaneous
acceleration now again this is sometimes
awkward to draw but you always must
remember that this X component of the
acceleration by definition is the second
derivative of the component function or
the first derivative of the component
function for the velocity and likewise
the Y component of the acceleration a Y
is the second derivative of the
component function for position and
that's also equal
by definition to the first derivative of
the component of the velocity vector and
that's how we describe the acceleration
as before we can talk about the
magnitude of a vector and the magnitude
of a we'll just write as a it's the
components squared added together taken
square root and that's our magnitude and
so now we've described all of our
kinematic quantities in two dimensions
the position the velocity as the
derivative of the position and the
acceleration as the derivative of the
velocity where each direction is treated
independently